pieces are increasing nationwide and
here in the valley as the omicron
variant of covid19 spreads so that means
you're going to want to get tested
either at a site around the valley or at
home before you go back to work or
school but the demand really is not
meeting the supply we have bianca holman
live this morning at a local pharmacy
bianca you spoke with folks about the
rush to get tested
yes well some people say it almost feels
like we're at the height of the pandemic
again with long lines at testing sites
and empty shells especially when it
comes to those at-home coven 19 tests
when you go on
pharmacy websites and you go to stores
like the one behind me it reads sold out
and so finding a take-home covet test in
the valley can be hit or miss
these tests are a hot ticket item
because it indicates within 10 to 15
minutes whether a person is infected
with covet or not the quick turnaround
makes at home tests a practical and
rapid way for people to know their
status especially if you just spent the
weekend in a large crowd ringing in the
new year we spoke with one walgreens
customer visiting from california about
the struggle to get tested
before returning to work or school
the government needs to really step it
up and just make sure that we have
access to all testing because how are
you going to know
what you got unless you get tests
now if you have a little bit of time and
need a test by the weekend
maybe you don't go for the at at-home
test but there are the regular pcr
testing sites that are still open
appointments are filling up fast on the
southern nevada health district website
so again be sure that you go in there i
was on there yesterday we were looking
at the possibility of getting tested
today a lot of sites filled up but they
did have openings for thursday and
friday so again just keep checking and
you may have to go to a site that's not
in your area of work or even your home
you'll have to go to another part of the
valley so keep that in mind and of
course we have all this information on
our website at 8 news now dot com bianca
holman live local now